e aí
oi boa noite
e eu quero te apresentar alguém mas eu
preciso antes dizer que tem pessoas que
tremem só de pensar em estar com ela tem
aqueles que aturam em momentos
importantes tem aqueles que observam bem
de perto e aqueles que a amam desde que
nascem para mim para mim ela é tudo ela
é minha melhor amiga está comigo nos
momentos mais felizes e nos mais tristes
também
e aos 18 anos eu perdi a minha mãe
e foi um processo de luto muito forte e
eu posso dizer que foi por causa dessa
amiga que eu consegui atravessar isso e
consegui expressar tudo que a mulher que
me deu a vida representava para mim
tá bom essa amiga maravilhosa e eu sei
que se você der uma chance para ela você
também vai se encantar a idade dela que
ela não me ouça mas ela é um tanto
ancestral não sei te precisar será alta
se ela é baixa muito menos enquadrá-lo
em padrões ela é fluida se veste de
muitas coisas e a fase mais atual tá no
estilo bem cigana provavelmente você
deixa de ser e se perguntando quem é ela
mas eu acho que você com certeza já
flertou com ela em algum momento da sua
vida e não precisa fazer essa cara de
espanto quando você pega um lápis uma
caneta escreve ou faz uma conta quando
você toma um banho ou quando você
e caminha você é vivem cia minha melhor
amiga minha melhor amiga e a dança ela
está comigo desde o jorrar certeiro em
terrenos fecundo que me permitiu existir
está comigo desde o espreguiçar em
líquido e nas ondas de contrações
uterinas que minha mãe senti ao me pare
está em cada impulso interno em cada
estímulo externo em cada crescer
oi e eu preciso te falar se ela tá
comigo ela também tá com você a estudos
que comprovam que existe dança desde
tempos pré-históricos todos os povos em
todos os tempos e lugares dançava só que
naquela época a dança não tinha tantas
regras ela era somente ir pulsar somente
ser ela era somente vida até hoje ela
perturba meu juízo querendo entender
como conseguiram criar réplicas dela em
que sobra exigência e cobrança e falta
sentimento e quando falta sentimento não
existe um terreno fértil para a
diversidade para empatia
e não existe um terreno fértil para a
criação
e nós passamos a vida temendo sermos
estranhos temendo não nos encaixar mas
temendo não dançar no ritmo certo mas
ritmo certo para quem por exemplo
e aí
oi essa dança é comum na índia
e essa é mais comum no brasil
e essa é mas como em salvador é
oi e essa mas como no rio sim cada
continente país estado e até bairro
existe uma expressão tão única porque
pensar que no universo inteiro você é o
único que tá falando ritmo mas ainda
porque pensar que a sua expressão tão
única é feia como eu falei no início
minha amiga a dança se veste de muitas
coisas ir o estilo mais atual é cigano
através do estudo da etnia arrumar eu
aprendi a respeitar a minha história ea
respeitar a história do outro através do
estudo da cultura cigana eu aprendi
sobre força sobre resiliência sobre
empatia através da prática da dança
cigana artística eu me transformo e
ajuda as minhas alunas a se
transformarem a dança cigana ela é um
mar de sentimento exatamente porque ela
é uma expressão de uma etnia
já passou por muitos altos e baixos e
ainda passa
é eu sei que pode parecer difícil mas
não é e a gente vai fazer isso agora
primeiro respira falar seja se ar agora
entrando no seu pulmão inflando e saída
se solta na cadeira fica à vontade vai
lá respira e solta inspira e solta
enquanto você tá nesse processo de
respiração eu vou te fazer uma pergunta
e você vai responder de forma mental se
o amor pudesse ser uma parte do seu
corpo que parte do seu corpo o amor
seria não julgue a primeira resposta que
vem na sua cabeça lá respira e se o amor
pudesse ser uma parte do meu corpo que
parte do meu corpo o amor seria agora eu
vou te pedir uma licença coloca a mão
nesse lugar
e aproveita que tá escuro não tô nem
vendo vai lá
a e agora que você colocou a mão nesse
lugar eu vou pedir para você imaginar
que esse lugar é uma fonte jorrando todo
esse amor do seu corpo inteiro e a gente
vai fazer assim a gente vai pegar esse
amor e vai dar
é porque amor compartilhado é amor
multiplicado então vai lá pega e coloca
para fora esse amor tira da fonte pode
ser a fonte em qualquer lugar gente em
qualquer lugar tira lá e da tira e da só
que a gente vai adicionar uma coisa todo
mundo algum momento já marchou sentado a
gente vai marcar pisa pisa pisa pego
amor e dar pego amor e da pode fazer com
as duas mãos com uma pequeno grande pego
amor e da fé do amor e da pega o amor e
dar
oi gente vocês já estão dançando tá
vendo não é tão difícil esse feito com
conexão se feito com paciência se feito
com carinho e ela fica ainda mais
gostoso e aí eu te pergunto o que te
impede agora de encontrar outro
sentimento no seu corpo e simplesmente
expressa ele ou tocar o que te impede de
verdade de pegar uma música que você
goste muito e simplesmente se expressar
através dela o que te impede de validar
sua dança e assim vale da dança do outro
seja ela no palco no evento ou no
chuveiro vai pega essa sementinha e
transforma ela numa onda de afeto tudo é
dança
e entra nesse processo se permitindo e
permitindo o outro também se expressar e
eu posso te dizer que provavelmente no
início meio e fim dessa jornada você
perceba que você suas movimentações e a
dança também sempre foram melhores
amigas obrigada
e aí